[door opening]
[exhales]
Francis, there is an
Englishman waiting for you.
These tables are no good.
No good at all.
He is from the
Hudson Bay Company.
I gave Lafarge
exact measurements.
A table that will
not tilt or list.
That is all I ask for, a
proper table, but this--
We will deal with the
table at the proper time.
There is a man.
He is wanting--
I said not now, Mathilde.
You have ruined my refinement.
Now what will we do?
We don't have money for
these refinements, Francis!
It is the floor that
is tilt, not the table.
I advised against
green wood planks,
but did you heed my advice?
No.
Everything here is poor
and broken and made wrong.
Even this.
It is no use.
These are unrefined tables
to serve unrefined food
for unrefined men.
That is our business, Francis.
[footsteps approaching]
A minute is a
minute, not five.
My apologies.
My husband and I were just--
Discussing refinements.
After a room?
HAMISH: Aye.
Two, actually.
He is my equal and will
be treated as such.
I have the other
guests to consider.
I wish to be civil
in all enterprises,
but I will not be denied a
proper room for my co-equal,
Yvon.
Though he can speak for himself.
YVON: Aye.
He is deadly with that book.
I am not his equal in that.
My apologies.
We will ready the rooms.
Thank you.
Mathilde Geffard.
Aye, Mathilde.
I wish to know about a
recent guest in your inn.
My husband keeps very careful
records of all the guests.
HAMISH: Well, then.
I am looking for a
Mr. Randall Cross.
That name is not
familiar to me.
HAMISH: He was an agent
for the Hudson Bay Company.
His correspondence indicate
that he was a guest at your inn.
He describes the
food as adequate,
though he did have a few words
of praise for the prune tart.
Exceptional, he wrote.
It can be, on occasion.
We would like to see the
room Mr. Cross stayed in.
Well, first I must check
to see if he was a guest.
Francis--
Stay out of this.
Aye, Mr. Cross was a guest.
He stayed in the Rose Suite.
He left us some time ago.
I just wanted to
make sure before--
I am sure.
These men do not have
time for games, Francis.